earlier today police apprehended the
gunman who killed four people in a
Nashville Waffle House the attack was
stopped with local hero James Shaw jr.
disarmed the shooter so once again yes
now once again proving the theory that
the only thing that stops a bad guy with
a gun is a good guy with a gun here for
insight our Second Amendment expert
Cobie Libby you hit the nail on the head
this evidence couldn't be more clear
this shooter was stopped by a good guy
with a gun yes good guys with guns are
how we stop bad guys with guns that's
just math let's hear about how the armed
hero did it the suspect opened fire and
was only stopped when James Shaw jr.
wrestled the gun away from the shooter
he tackled the shooter he got the gun
away from him and then he took the gun
and threw it across the counter this
unarmed man James saw jr. disarming the
shooter did she say unarmed yes got to
be a mistake right he must have had a
gun that's how you stop guns yeah she
definitely said unarmed I mean why did
we think he was armed yeah why were we
so certain that man was armed Chuck can
we get a picture of James Shaw jr. up
wait where's the gun well it's right no
uh it's right maybe maybe maybe now it's
the craziest thing I was initially so
certain he had a gun but now that I've
taken time to assess the situation I
just I don't see it yeah let's check a
different picture with that accident I
think that's that's just as hand where
the hell is the gun okay I mean what
what if he really didn't have a gun
anyone would have thought he had a gun
should we uh turn the cameras off and
get our story straight yeah Chuck okay
don't panic it's not like we're
predisposed to thinking he was armed
Jesus if that were true I would need
intense training to change my immediate
reaction to that guy look look we got to
get on the same page if anyone asks the
picture had a gun
absolutely the picture had a gun Chuck
okay well regardless of how Shaw did it
if either of us had been there you
better believe we would have stopped the
shooter with our guns I actually don't
have a gun Jordan sure you do
yeah I know
[Laughter]
why'd you think that because you're
patriotic you better believe me
everybody the fight continues